The output of each week in the Robotic Vision
Project will be to write a function in MATLAB.
Functions are very important in programming
and also for this project, so let's take a
look now at a simple example that I've put
together in MATLAB.
Functions are really important with programming
and they're really useful, so if you're new
to MATLAB or just programming in general,
you really need to be aware about how they
do really make your life easier.
So functions is basically just a collection
of programming lines that can be used repeatedly
with just one function call; so they basically
obstruct away or hide some code that we've
already written and the project is basically
going to be you guys each week making a new
function to solve a particular task. So as
you're doing the project or any programming
problem in general, if you’re starting to
copy and paste code that you've written before,
you really need to be thinking about "Okay,
should I be actually copying and pasting it
or should I be making new functions?" And
as you make a new function you also need to
think about what sort of parameters these
functions should have, so what are the inputs
to the function?
So if you have good and robust inputs that
means that the function can be used to be
solve other types of problems and it will
also be useful for other people using your code.
So that's my spiel on functions; they're very
useful and I've put together a simple example
of a MATLAB function, so let's go through
that right now.
Okay so I have a function here called "greysmooth"
so let's take a look at that function and
this function contains some comments and I'm
going to go through this line by line and
we're going to see how MATLAB functions work.
So the function greysmooth has two inputs,
the first is img which is the input image
and the second is the kernel size. Now this
kernel size dictates the smoothing that occurs
on my output image which will be the input
image but converted into greyscale and then
smoothed over. Okay so that's what the function
greysmooth is going to do.
For MATLAB functions, they always start with
the key word of "Function" and they always
finish with the key word of "End".
Now with functions, the first variable that
you type after the key word is the upper variables
and for my function here for this demonstration
I just have one, which is called "simg" and
that is equal to the name of your function,
so my name's obviously greysmooth and coincidently
the name of the function also needs to be
the name of the MATLAB file, so greysmooth.m
and the greysmooth function.
After that you've put some brackets and then
you have the input parameters for your function.
So for greysmooth we have two inputs, img which is the input image and then the kernel size which is M.
Okay, so that's the declaration
of MATLAB functions.
The first step I want to do in my function
is to generate a greyscale version of the
input image, so I'm going to create a new
variable and we'll call the imono function,
and that will take in my input image and then
convert it into greyscale.
The next step is to actually create the smoothing
kernel, so I'll make another variable called
"K" and then I’ll create my smoothing kernel.
So you can already see here, the power of
functions. So if I wanted to call greysmooth,
I can then supply a smooth smoothing kernel
size and then that will change the ends inside
the function. Now if you didn't write this,
if you were just typing these commands in
the MATLAB workspace you would have to go
back and retype out the kernel line again
and then substitute N for the different numbers
that you wanted, but because we've written
it as a function, every time we call it the
computer will then do the work for us and
it will change the N inside.
The last step is to actually create the smooth
output image; so we will use my simg variable
and then call the icon function and icon takes
in the kernel size and the greyscale image.
Okay so that's my greysmooth function. Let's
go into the MATLAB workspace now and test it out.
So first thing I need to do before I do that,
is actually import an image, so I will call
in my iread function, read in the Robotic
Vision worksheet like so and now I can generate
a smooth image, so I call my greysmooth, import
this image and let's do a smoothing of say 25.
Okay so that's smoothed the input image and
let's take a look at that smoothed image.
So you can see we've taken in our Robotic
Vision worksheet image and it's applied a
smoothing on top of that, so you can see its
a little bit blurry comparative to the normal image.
Okay, so say we wanted to increase the amount
of smoothing, with our function, so because
we've written a function we can just call
it again and let's increase the smoothing
from 25 to say 50. Okay so that's smoothed
it using a kernel size of 50 and then we can
use the idisp command again to visualize both
images at the same time; so on the left hand
side I have my first image which had a kernel
size of 25 and then in the right we have my
smoothed image again, but this time using
a kernel size of 50 and you can see it's much
more blurry this time.
So I hope this demonstration of functions
shows you the power and how useful they are,
so for the project you'll be writing a new
function each week to achieve a particular task.
And just note that the size of your functions
should not be that large, they should be round
about 100 lines or less of code and if you're
functions are larger than that, then you should
really take a step back and think about the
way you've approached the problem and maybe
you're algorithm needs to be improved.